So, how useful is active network? There
are lots of potential applications that can be
built using this active network's paradigm. In
particular, what we want to do is, when
ever we desire certain ways to visualize
the behavior of the network. Then active networks
become very useful. So, for instance, for
implementing protocol independent multicast reliable multicast, or noticing
congestions in the network and notifying the source
and the destination about the congestions, private IP, any
casting. These are all the kinds of things
that are useful to implement using active networks. And
as you can see from this list, the kinds of things that you want to do, using
active networks, are things that are related to network
functionality. Not high-level application,
but network functionality. In particular,
it is useful for building applications that are difficult to
deploy in the internet. So, when you rely on the
routing and the internet, it is entirely an administrative set
up, and the administrative set up tends to mirror the
physical set up. But, for your particular network flow, you
may want a set up that is different from the
physical set up. And the example I give you of
me sending a greeting that will be a single message
for most of the traverse through the internet,
but at some point, it may actually get demultiplexed
and get sent to several different destinations. Those
kinds of multicasting and things like that, are specific
to network flow. So, we are in some
sense, overlaying our own desire on topology, on top
of the physical topography of the internet, by using
the active network paradigm. But, the key properties that
you want to have for applications that you want
to build using the active networks paradigm, is that
the applications should be expressible and it should be
compact and it should be fast and it should not
rely on all the notes being active. These are
key things to note in building applications that live on
top of the active networks. So all of these
suggest, once again, what I said already and that is,
it is for providing network layer functionality,
not end application functionality. So, what you want
in the network layer, that is something
that again orchestrate using the active networks paradigm.